coming to the cultural catastrophe
several months ago dinesh d'souza
appeared on this program and I want to
show the audience what he said about you
I would say that the person who has had
a big influence on me uh would be sort
of my mentor which is Jeffrey hard an
English professor at Dartmouth because
here was a guy who was conservative but
not in a boring way here's a guy who
would who was playful in fact he would
sometimes walk around the campus in a
large raccoon coat with a button that
said humorously soak the poor his idea
was to infuriate other professors and
get them to argue with him and so on but
he was a very colorful character who was
generally genuinely interested in ideas
and he opened up for me a world of
literature and philosophy that has
immeasurably enriched my life what's
your reaction when you hear that from
one of your former students pride why
because if I was was if I had were in
part responsible for jinesh d'souza look
what he's done he's published several
very important books and to the extent
that i did have any influence on on him
I'm glad I did how many books have you
written in your life this is the eighth
and this book is smiling through the
cultural catastrophe what led up to you
writing this and what's it about well
one of the three epigraphs in theirs
from Solzhenitsyn and he says a people
that has lost its memory has lost its
history and its soul and one trying to
do in this book is give the reader an
impression of the intellect that lies
behind Western civilization which you
and I at this moment inhabit and i feel
that a great deal of memory has been
lost that now if you think of yourself
as an individual and if you lost all
memory of your childhood and adolescence
education so you'd be bewildered hardly
would hardly be able to locate yourself
and so I'm trying to locate people in
the intellectual matrix of Western
civilization now we all notice
that the symbols with which Western
civilization declares itself think of
the Golden Gate Bridge or the Empire
State Building or salads Barry Cathedral
a very different from the Great Wall of
China or the Forbidden City so the idea
that informs the civilization is very
different from the idea that informs
Chinese civilization or Indian
civilization for that matter so what I'm
trying to do in this book is reintroduce
the reader to his own civilization on
the cover of this book as their faith I
think it's supposed to be Shakespeare
and it's it's it was done by electronic
digital reproduction so what that is
trying to say i think is a combination
of the past and the present and the
future what impact has Shakespeare had
on us either in the past or the present
well it's he pervades the language
expressions in Shakespeare our you know
bruited about we think through
Shakespeare to it to a considerable
extent how to be or not to be the
quality of Mercy is not strained at
droppeth as the gentle rain from heaven
upon the earth beneath this Porsche oh
you know you could just go on and on and
we get him not only directly from the
plays but through other poets who
learned to write bye-bye a bobbing
Shakespeare how much did Shakespeare
right in his life um it's about 30 plays
and some poems and the sonnets so he
wrote he was very productive Mark Van
Doren used to say that if he could do it
easily couldn't have done it at all you
know because people have been
interpreting Hamlet or Lear for four
centuries and apparently he just wrote
these things the way Mozart wrote his
operas who learned from Shakespeare and
like you said earlier and how do you
know that well his influence is
pervasive in the Elizabethan drama and
the Jacobean drama Milton compete
with Shakespeare wrote a different kind
of verse because Shakespeare he couldn't
he couldn't match Shakespeare and so he
did something else Samuel Johnson
preface to Shakespeare is one of the
best pieces of literary criticism in
English I think it was he he put he did
an edition of the all the plays and
commented on them but his preface is a
major work of criticism in your
acknowledgments you mentioned not only
Mark Van Doren but Jacques barson and
Lionel trilling yes who were those three
men and why did you give them that your
gratitude well I spent my first two
years freshman and sophomore at
Dartmouth and then simply resigned I
what the English department in those
days was very uninteresting and I
remember one day sitting down on a bench
and say saying what do I really want to
spend two more years at this and doesn't
the answer was no Howard you got into
Dartmouth where were you from Long
Island my father was a Dartmouth
graduate class of 21 and he registered
registered be and Dartmouth when I was
born of course I had to get admitted but
that was a detail and anyway I went to
Stuyvesant High School here in New York
has a very competitive school you had to
take an exam to get in and i found the
professors at dartmouth that I met in
1947 be not as good as my high school
teachers so I sort of going backwards
and so I quit and got a job with a
publisher our dual Sloan and peers I'd
written up some sketches and stories and
things and they hired me as a low level
editor and working for a publisher I got
in with literary people around New York
book parties and the like and some
Columbia people ask me why aren't you in
college and I said what I just told you
and they said what would you give
Columbia chance so I went to Columbia
for my junior and senior years and
graduated maybe and at Columbia which I
think was probably the strongest English
department in the country Mark Van Doren
Lionel trilling Quentin Anderson Fred do
p Jacques Parsons and hist
of course but this was quite a team and
it was then I didn't think I was going
to be college professor but it was then
at Columbia and juniors seniors I
decided this is the kind of thing I want
to do and I spent four years in naval
intelligence courtesy of North Korea and
came back to Colombia for a PhD and I
remember I was walking around in
Hamilton Hall getting my course card
signed and the chamber came out as if
I'd not been away for four years and he
said they are hard how would you like to
teach freshman English so it was hired
and taught that in the humanities course
to it buried in this book of yours you
tell a couple stories around Colombia
Whittaker Chambers names came up and
also Carol wax name mm-hmm and
Ginsburg's name and others would tell
that whole story about why did you put
that in here well it was an introduction
to my section on Dostoevsky and
specifically on Raskolnikov and crime
and punishment and Raskolnikov is the
ultimate student you know he lives in a
hovel it's a mess he thinks he's
Napoleon he thinks about himself all the
time he has terrible guilty commits a
terrible crime now Raskolnikov could
occur at Columbia he was in st.
Petersburg at the time but that kind of
student somehow is around Colombia and
Whittaker Chambers was very dusty ask
Ian figure I mean can you imagine
someone from Princeton sitting down and
trying to decide whether he should
commit suicide or join the Communist
Party no but at Columbia you can and
whittaker chambers did good that yes and
you decide to join the car and this was
long before the depression the country
was prosperous things were going well
you could read The Great Gatsby and so
forth and he hears this gloomy character
thinking Russian thoughts in the middle
of the Columbia campus what about Cara
wagon Allen Ginsberg
kerouac the Columbia legend is that he
walked off the football field to become
an artist writer no he walked off to
join the military because he was very
patriotic and then the war was on so we
went to Boston got drunk and he joined
the army the Navy and the Merchant
Marine all the same time committing a
federal crime and somehow it was covered
up and they let him stay in the Merchant
Marine Lucien Carr Lucien Carr was a
hanger-on around the campus columbia
columbia right and he committed a murder
because someone may someone he knew
another man made a pass at him in
Morningside Park and he killed him and
threw threw the body in the Hudson River
and the course was found and he came to
Ginsburg knew about this occurrence and
so did Kerouac who is living in
Ginsburg's dormitory room and you know
these these people not professor
moriarty of crime they threw the knife
down a subway grating or something I did
yes right and they got what they got
away with it because Ginsburg pleaded
insanity and somehow Kerouac really
hadn't done anything so Ginsberg went to
a mental hospital for a while and Lucien
Carr served time you say he served two
years yes and then William Burroughs you
go on to tell a little story I only
bring us up because these are all little
little stories about having around
Colombia sure Burroughs lived in the
village but he circulated around with
these people too and close friend is a a
really awful person he belonged to the
burrows business machine family and he
was a serious dope addict and a
homosexual and he married a woman
for some reason probably set it sadistic
he told Ginsburg that women were unclean
and that so what burrows did was get up
an act for cocktail party purpose and
shoot a glass of water off her head with
a revolver in the course of this type of
thing he missed the glass of water and
shot her right through the fart killed
her and this was in Mexico and he got
away with weapons violation charge it
didn't wasn't wasn't trying for murder
came back and wrote Naked Lunch which is
a drug soaked horrible thing so how many
years did you spend toll at Columbia
seven then left there in what year 63
went where Dartmouth um Dora position
opened up at Dartmouth in my field which
was the 18th century English literature
and this looked very good and I accepted
it going back to the dish there's a clip
when he mentioned you at the program I
immediately remembered you writing
newspaper columns in this town I think
in the Washington star used to publish
it years ago because they're not even in
business any longer and I said something
of course like is he still around yeah
and word got back to you that you are
very much still around what are you
doing now just finished writing this
book I have another book mostly finished
called snapshots from heaven it's a
memoir it's not an autobiography it's a
snapshots of interesting people
interesting experiences the Navy working
for Reagan and 68 Nixon and 68 and then
the Nixon campaign in 72 Nixon himself
didn't campaign in 72 and Bill Buckley
and National Review and James Burnham
and tennis tennis has been a very big
thing in my life I grew up really at the
Westside Tennis Club in forest hills and
played intercollegiate tennis both of
Dartmouth and Columbia before I forget
it what are those little items on your
lapel this is an antique Columbia pin my
wife is an antiques dealer and she she
knows I like these things
and that is from 1912 it's a bull moose
from the Teddy Roosevelt campaign in
1912 and you have another little is that
little button down there well my book
was published by the yale university
press and nancy found this antique yale
button yes somewhere we had just a side
a little bit yeah there we go I think
sort of a party favor that someone would
give a date for the weekend you know
sort of a keepsake is that a special toy
you have on their wisdom yeah this is a
all the most of the old all the way
going back to the colonial days of the
American flag the Thames rattlesnake
flag you know don't tread on me and so
forth these and n sons of difference it
was custom-made not for me but I managed
to talk the shop into selling it to me
now what about this raccoon coat and
what dinesh d'souza said he liked you
because you weren't boring conservative
right well mostly concerns I know aren't
boring I mean who ever think Bill
Buckley was boring anyway I bought this
raccoon coat at a ski area in northern
Vermont and it waited like 50 pounds of
tremendous coat I would wear it to
football games for fun as a kind of a
retrospective gesture toward the 1920s
now this book is full of Socrates and
Plato and Aristotle and Jesus and
Shakespeare and on and on no stay after
you mentioned big question for you is
what can we learn if we spend a lot of
time in this book about what this
country is going through today what
value is it okay very briefly the core
of this book can be designated
internalization we have in Moses and
Achilles too late bronze age figures
around 1250 a pc now both of these are
heroic figures who act Achilles a great
warrior Moses a warrior 2 and lawgiver
but it's how you should behave really
Achilles wants to be noble heritage is
the Greek word noble and nobility is a
complicated idea in Homer but let's just
call it the heroic Moses heroic to what
you get on the Greek side is the
internalization of the Homeric heroic in
heroic philosophy in Socrates Plato
designed Socrates in that in the
dialogues as a better teacher than Homer
in other words Socrates stands for
intellect and cognition you understand
the world through mind over in Jerusalem
we were all familiar with Moses Ten
Commandments thou shot nut shalt not
steal commit adultery whatever Jesus
internalizes the mosaic behavior code as
in as spiritual aspiration not only
should you not commit adultery far from
it you shouldn't even think of it you
should be he uses the front of the
metaphorical a whitewashed tomb whited
Sepulcher white outside and corrupt
within the Sermon on the Mount wants you
to be white all the way through you
don't you you would not take an oath
according to him because you would never
think of lying you just wouldn't so we
get on the one hand Socratic cognition
and on the other hand Jesus spiritual
aspiration and those are the two poles I
think between which the Western mind
moves you said by the way in your book
took Jesus and Socrates never wrote a
word that's right never they never got
tenure either how do we know so much
about both of them because other people
told their story in what way how do they
do it little four Gospels Matthew Mark
Luke and John and Plato and the dialogue
Socrates is the the post heroic hero in
Plato you point out when it comes to the
gospel
that those are written now no words were
written down about Jesus for 30 years
after his death that's right how do you
trust then what was said 30 years later
well I think the most important one of
the most important passages in the New
Testament was all written in Greek by
the way speaking of Athens in Jerusalem
in first Corinthians chapter 15 this is
a public letter to the congregation in
Corinth from pole he says I'll pile just
approximate the thing brethren 300 of
you saw Jesus after his resurrection
some of you have gone to sleep Dodd but
others are still here so I think the
story began to be written down so it
wouldn't be lost the witnesses were
going to die and the oral tradition of
what happened would fade away unless
they wrote it down and so you got these
four things and scholars think that they
may have been based on something called
a cue doctrine of document but we don't
have that what we have is what what got
written down well when did Socrates live
compared to when Jesus lived 400 BC so
he lived 400 years before Christ and how
long after Socrates death and how did he
die it did play til write down what he
had to say Socrates was charged with
debasing morals and starting attempting
to start a new religion I think he
certainly wasn't debasing morals he was
extremely moral person but he certainly
was an enemy of the polytheism that was
the state religion and it wasn't just a
matter of opinion you know that thena
and so forth they had temples built to
them priests and priestesses and so
forth holidays so Socrates was really
causing trouble
by saying not polytheism but philosophy
and his philosophy was not saying
empiricism or pragmatism or something it
was it was moving in the direction of
monotheism so he was troublesome to the
whole state of things in Athens and I
forgotten what the vote was that
convicted him but it was it was pretty
narrow I mean he almost almost let him
go but then how long was it after he
died too and Plato wrote dialogues about
a decade and then he played a little e85
and he continued to write you know and
then by the way that the dialogues we
have our popular works in the Academy he
taught much more concentrated
dialectical philosophy and to
Aristotle's came to the Academy and
stayed there for 18 years so this was
not an easy curriculum let me keep going
back to the basics if somebody you know
the Twin Towers in New York six thousand
people dead what can people or can
people come to this book and this
thought process and learn anything about
why something like that would happen
sure the civilization this book
describes its intellectual basis you
could go at through music or
architecture whatever is a supremely
successful civilization the background
of these people like bin Laden or
Mohammed Atta is a failed culture it's
going nowhere between the shores of the
Mediterranean and the border of India
there's almost nothing there isn't a
decent government except for Israel yes
these places who wants to go to Syria we
prop up Egypt two billion a year they
are not in a position to challenge the
West except with a kind of poor man's
war slamming into the Twin Towers trying
to spread anthrax I mean this is pretty
ridiculous because Western science
coming from Socratic cognition and
through the
through the development of science now
can produce bombs that make a very very
big explosion so if we want to stop the
anthrax anytime we can they know that I
think it's a we mentioned Shakespeare
before and Yago says of Cassio of hand
sewn and wonderful soldier he says casio
has a daily beauty in his life that
makes me ugly so he hates casio for the
very thing that you'd normally admire
and tries to involve them in a plot so i
think that the Western civilization has
a daily beauty in its life that makes
Islam ugly when you say makes is on the
religion ugly yes those listening who
are Muslims would immediately quarrel
you they think they have a beautiful
religion yeah turn on TV and see mob
screaming in the street and saying long
live Ben Laden and I don't think this is
a minority or fringe opinion then Laden
I mean he's the Che Guevara of Islam and
very very popular not with sophisticated
Muslims or you know scholars or
something but the religion at some point
must connect with this kind of terrorism
what do you say then it what if those
people think they're right that believe
in their Quran and believe in their God
and that they say we western people
think they have the answer but they are
the infidels well I'll just say they're
wrong and look where they're look where
they are look how they treat women they
cover them up in all kinds of stuff they
the Taliban won't even got a woman
wounds eyes show
in public this strikes me as grotesque
and I don't think it's just a matter of
opinion I tried to read the Quran once
and it's not like the Bible the nearest
thing in the Bible to it it would be the
Book of Revelations it's full of
symbolism and mysterious things it's not
that the Bible has actual people doing
things that you can recognize is actual
people doing the Korean is a much
murkier state of affairs apparently
dictated to well hammered by a talking
goat this is very strange stuff and I
just don't don't see it as a equivalent
of Christianity or Judaism you mentioned
that I Islam the way they treat women
what about the Catholic Church and their
attitude toward women can you explain
that in history why and maybe other
religions and other groups why they
separate the men from the women and in
the Catholic Church for instance the
women aren't allowed to be priests and
that's what you can't marry yeah I think
in time the Catholic Church will have
one as pleased but what's the mentality
now what's the base for the way they
think now well the way they explain it
so far as I understand it is that no
women were among the original disciples
and those are the four bears of the
priesthood now one can say that in those
days it would have been impossible for
women to be among the disciples but look
at the status that Mary gets in the
Catholic Church she and and Mary
Magdalene was the first one to see the
empty tomb go back again to your basic
the characters in your book and have
been written about over the years if
they were to come to life today what
would they think of what's happened to
the world in the last three four hundred
years would they be surprised I
certainly think Achilles or Jesus would
be Shakespeare would be surprised I mean
place looks so much different from
anything there I'm accustomed to a good
seminar topic when I've discussed these
things with students as did Jesus know
Greek I think he did because everybody
did paul wrote in Greek the Greek was
the language of the civilized world in
those days so yes he probably did and
also he was very precocious he disputed
with the rabbi's in the temple when he
was very young probably irritated them
no end yeah that probably would be
surprised but sometimes wonder what it
would be like to meet Jesus as he
appears comes at us from the narratives
I remember for example a rich young man
comes up and Jesus says sell everything
you have and give them eyes the poor now
he must have seen something about that
man that told him that wealth was too
important to him because fancy clothes I
was pairing or something he saw that
wealth was a problem standing between
purity and the way is so I think he
would be very perceptive about you if
you just look and see and then the one
good thing about Peter is that as soon
as Jesus says follow me he drops all his
fish nets and follows him so he had the
perception that this was very unusual
person and so Jesus made him number one
even though he's brought stupid and
Jesus has to spell out what the parables
me and so forth and Peter's almost
comical because he's the last one to get
to the empty to apparently he doesn't
run well so and but nevertheless Jesus
was something about this man that so I
think he was very very perceptive are
you still teaching no I'm not not in the
classroom anymore when did you stop that
how about five years ago from all the
studying you done in a reading you done
and the writing you've done where do you
personally come out after all these
years when it comes to your own religion
I became a Catholic in 1968 I was an i
went to the Episcopal Church at Columbia
and Reverend John crumb was the chaplain
there and very very good and the
Episcopal Church through John crumb
seemed to me to be strong intellectually
well sat founded well based but when I
left Columbia and went to the let's say
the infantry of the Episcopal Church I
found it rather thin and as a after a
lot of reflection I remember just before
I went out to Sacramento to write
speeches for Reagan I became a Catholic
in New Hampshire and what's happened
your catholicity since nineteen
sixty-eight I'm deep deepening and I
really love the Catholic Church for its
two thousand year history and so forth
and naturally the people going to find
things to quarrel with it but Jacques
Martin and in the first sentence of his
peasant of the Quran as a final book
said thank God for the visible Church
yeah I thank God for the visible Church
I don't done Andrew Greeley priests in
Chicago said a wise thing he said when
you when you find the perfect Church
join it and then it won't be perfect
anymore when did you become a
conservative I think when when I was
growing up my parents were Republicans
and what that meant to them was good
government on the tom dooley model clean
up corruption and so forth from there
they didn't they didn't think of
themselves as conserved I think they
thought of themselves as a modern
progressive good government people from
their point of view the Democratic Party
was the urban bosses Flynn of the Bronx
and you know the what's his name curly
in Massachusetts that kind of that kind
of person Big Labor and the solid
Democratic South q Klux Klan
so there were Republicans and opposed
all that though not conservative i think
the term conservative began to be widely
used during the Cold War F 1945 as
opposed to socialism and communism and
then Edmund Edmund Burke very
importantly was rediscovered so a
conservative I think that my political
allegiance goes to say Montaigne David
Hume Tocqueville Burke anti utopian
skeptical prudential not expecting too
much so that's one mode of conservative
conservative um thought and feeling oaks
at how did you get involved with Ronald
Reagan Bill Buckley was having Reagan
won in 1966 by a million votes over Pat
Brown Bill Buckley was having lunch with
him at pacific palisades and Reagan was
acting as if he was going to run for
president the conversation just tended
that way what year again 60 this is a 67
and so bill said to Reagan you need a
Sorensen which is loosely defined as own
who puts quotations from Heraclitus into
the candidates speech and so bill called
me at home and said you want to go out
and write speeches for Reagan and I said
what I have to go to California yes so I
decided to to do that and took the
spring semester off from Dartmouth and
lived in Sacramento and worked in
Reagan's office and what was your
reaction to the experience very positive
first of all I didn't know what a
political speech was and so I went to
the library and read some famous
political speeches and with my literary
background I recognize it as a
distinctive genre it's not instruction
it's to establish communion between the
candidate and the in the audience that
he understands their concerns
even if he can't solve all their
problems immediately he's with them he
has to make that that connection there's
a wonderful old joke about franklin
roosevelt coming to New York Darwin
who's president and coming down Fifth
Avenue and has opened the mazine crowds
lining the sidewalks and these two men
come out of their office and they're
standing there suddenly as rosal does by
one of the guys starts jumping up and
down and yelling hooray for rozsival
longer roll up wonderful again and the
other his friend says well that man
can't do anything for you and he says I
know that but he knows my bosses an sob
now you went from there at one point to
Richard Nixon right Nixon beat Reagan at
the miami convention and I was driving
had bought an old foul ball in
Sacramento on his driving across I'd
given the governor's office my itinerary
and I got a phone call in some awful
motel in the middle of some terrible
desert and it was Nixon's office at 450
Park Avenue and would I stop by and
consider joining that team and it turned
out to be very very interesting and the
team was a strong bill sapphire pat
buchanan ray price alan greenspan was
our research director and you know so
this was quite a quite a thing and I i
wrote Nixon's famous lon auto speech I
think he gave it in Pittsburgh it flew
flew in the campaign playing down there
and worked on the speech to the last
minute I think it was Pittsburgh but it
might have been Philadelphia you know
when a campaign plan you don't really
know what city you're in and they all
threw his time you're teaching no i took
the eye i took the this was all through
the summer into the fall we say and the
when classes started again in
late-september i went back and taught
you know they have but continued to file
copy for the Nixon campaign so in
history Ronald Reagan's position will be
and in history Richard Nixon's position
will be
I think if you take Truman in 1945 and
Reagan and his two terms they're like
bookends around world war three against
the Soviet Union Truman did what he had
to do with NATO the Marshall Plan and so
forth and resisting the Korean invasion
and Reagan ended it with the fall of the
Berlin Wall so that's a quite a hunk of
history if I had to say one thing about
Reagan if it was for a lot of things
lower taxes less government so on so on
but yes and sincerely but I think when
he got up in the morning and looked in
the mirror and brushed his teeth the
first thing he thought of was what can I
do today to weaken the Soviet Union that
was his central Central thing that he
did a lot to do that go back to your
book first let me ask you this if you
had a choice of reading your favourite
newspaper or reading Plato or one of the
other people in your book on any given
day which would be your first choice
well I was always read the newspaper
with breakfast they don't they aren't
necessarily competing valuables you go
to them for different things where do
you get your most enjoyment reading
Plato and the people i talked about you
know i'm not saying this from any
political point of view but the New York
Times is a great newspaper but there is
a feeling of mental let me take one step
back when Jesse Helms announced his
retirement that part of whatever anyone
thinks of jesse hell's the time said
that he resisted the tide of
enlightenment and progress now that kind
of prose has a feeling of death about it
you know i'm not aware of being a tide
of enlightenment and progress and eNOS
is the Broadway theater better now than
it was
20s I don't think so this kind of
writing is you know you feel almost that
you're losing brain cells as you submit
to that kind of prose and instead though
it's a great newspaper but with these
people you don't that that language is
really alive and you feel you're getting
smarter you do some biography on some
people want to ask you about some of
them Paul Paul when did he live he was
contemporary with Jesus came from Tarsus
which is in southern part of what we now
call Turkey he was a rabbi he was said
to describes a tentmaker now this didn't
drink doesn't mean pup tents these were
very elaborate structures that people
move down the great caravan routes and
and the sort of headquarters tents he
did that he was a preacher in the
synagogue in Tarsus and one of the great
Paul's st. Paul scholars author dhabi
Knox of Harvard late author dobranoc
thinks that Jesus may have also preached
in the in the synagogue at tarsus and
conceivably Paul saw him we don't know
can't tell however on the road to
Damascus Paul had a drastic confirm
conversion experience fell off his horse
as fact and felt the power of jesus and
his teaching must have reached him in
some way and became a became a Christian
and and an evangelist the Roman order
and the Roman roads enabled him to
travel all over the Near East and
finally through Athens to to Rome he
preached in Athens so for me Paul's a
symbol of Athens and Jerusalem he wrote
in Greek you spoke Greek he was part of
the Roman world of the Greek world and
he ended in I think who had 65 ad in
Rome where he was arrested it's not
quite clear what for the Romans were
very tolerant
you could believe whatever you want as
long as didn't cause trouble and I think
something about Paul made them nervous
and they beheaded him you say he did not
know Jesus we can't tell this Paul
scholar Arthur Dhabi Knox thinks he
might have but you know a scholar like
this goes to all the material in the
manuscripts and inferences and so forth
and he thinks they might across paths
but he won't commit himself to say he
did how important is Paul very and why
because he had the energy and the
eloquence to spread the message
throughout the then known world
including Rome you say in your book Paul
we know was a constant source of
excitement and contention during his
travels and even stirred at riots how
did you do that by preaching the life
death and resurrection of Jesus and he
settled all kinds of quarrels in these
evangelized communities like Corinth for
example there are all kinds of questions
of belief than theology and so on coming
up and Paul was a he must have been a
very persuasive and diplomatic figure
you mentioned earlier but I want you to
go back over one more time because you
start your book this way the contrast
between Athens and Jerusalem why is that
one of your major themes in the book
good question Nia Athens with the figure
Socrates in the foreground stands for
understanding the world through
intellect in other words Athens stands
for philosophy and science Plato leaning
more toward philosophy Aristotle
bringing science to bear on things
Jerusalem stands for the aspiration to
spiritual perfection first through Moses
then through Jesus and I think there's a
tension between these two things that
creates mental activity you don't have
an idea unless really you're confronted
with a contradiction Lionel trilling
says that in keith's the idea of love
and the idea of death produce his lyric
impulse contradiction
Athens and Jerusalem are in tension off
at the edge do you trust intellect or do
trust spirituality we hope you don't
have to choose and I think the West
doesn't choose Leo Strauss a modern
philosopher said agro-based that's right
he's he's dead now but very much a
presence he thinks that democracy
depends on maintaining the both end
quality of cognition and spirituality
that a monk might choose spirituality
above everything a philosopher might
choose cognition above everything but
the society should not it should keep
keep both options available I think I
think Strauss is right about that if
you're going to go for pure pure
rationality you come up with something
like Plato's Republic not very pleasant
and if you go for pure spirituality
you'd be in a monastery and this society
would be a monastery which I don't think
i would like so yes I think they put
another way the educated man knows too
much to be a relativist not enough to be
an absolutist somewhere in there is
freedom when you taught all this and I
assume you talked us in school sure what
was the reaction of your students and I
mean Dartmouth students get in there got
to be pretty bright now they're very
bright and they get excited there if
they feel challenged how do you notice
it they start competing with you and
your interpretations and you know that
they get smarter and smarter and I think
it's great fun really can they ever get
under your skin or did they they don't
the most discouraging thing I have found
as a teacher's is the experience you a
young man comes into discusses essay
with you and it suddenly dawns on you
that I'm more interested in the paper
than he is you know
they said well what are we doing and
that that's irritating Hanover New
Hampshire home of Dartmouth is the
atmosphere there's what's it like it's
changed over the years right after the
war when I first went to Dartmouth was
full of veterans and in a physical way
it was pretty rough place now it's very
wealthy the goods on sale and main
street hanover you know these students
are buying four hundred dollars skis and
Brooks Brothers times I close and so on
and so rather beautiful and stylish I
think how do you get them interested in
this kind of stuff well not everyone is
the liberal arts are not vocational
training graduate schools vocational
training medicine law whatever the
liberal arts are not how to do anything
is but how to be and if the student
understands that and wants to be better
than he is this is a very exciting thing
to do again get back to it today is
there any way to understand what's going
on say in the Palestine Israel all that
all that over there from the history of
this from what you're writing about back
in Jerusalem Athens well why people
today are fighting over this yeah whole
issue the most volatile thing most
volatile faction in Islam and I don't
think it's small faction is the very
strict version of Islam represented by
bin Laden what he wants to do is
overthrow the Saudi government and
perhaps around the country himself and
what he would establish is something
like the Taliban obviously this is a
losing idea the Taliban isn't going
anywhere except death the the idea that
you're going to set up an Islamic utopia
based on Taliban like stretches is
farcical so that part of the world has a
big problem and the only way it can go
as
is toward modernization the global
economy and so forth of course they
didn't have oily have nothing but the
strict bin Laden direction is the
opposite of modernization that's going
over but what about Jesus coming back
today and seeing what's going on right
in Jerusalem hmm stand right in the
middle of Jerusalem today old Jerusalem
whoa what about his feeling be about
what's going on Norma's disappointment
why because the intransigence and the
random killings and blowing up disco sex
and I think those are killing yesterday
in Bethlehem of all places this is a
mess would he have any solution to the
problem well if you if you go back you
know the parable of the Good Samaritan
where the the guy has beaten up and left
in a ditch by thieves and then the Good
Samaritan the man from Samaria comes
along and it's dangerous on the Jericho
Road but he risks his own situation fix
the guy up takes him in i think if you
consider that parable what should the
Samaritan have done had he come along 20
minutes earlier and saw the thieves
beating him up he might have to take his
sword and interfere kill him Jesus
doesn't rule that out but he what he
rules out is anger the Good Samaritan
should not behave like Achilles killing
Hector with fury and bloodlust he should
kill him with regret that anyone should
be so deformed as to try to hold this
guy up now sure to that or having done
that what should the Good Samaritan have
done I think formed State Police to to
look over things on the Jericho Road
practical love again going back to the
some of the other characters you write
about in your book Voltaire why so much
attention to Voltaire well I deal with
who was he first he was a comprehensive
literary man and political reformer
critic of the
monarchy in church of his day he really
admired the parliamentary monarchy they
had in England when he visited England
to you he would have clinically settled
for that but it was impossible to do
that with the absolute monarchy that the
French had however he was a playwright a
historian wrote a great history of the
year of the reign of a fluid 14th he
wrote a lot of poetry and I discussed
his satire Candide which I value for the
energy of its that's comic sense it's a
very funny book and Moses I know I'm
jumping all around here but these are
characters all throughout the book and I
want you to tell us what you can about
well Moses was born a Hebrew and his
mother to keep him the Pharaoh Pharaoh
out of the firstborn killed and she put
him in a little basket like boat and he
was rescued by gyptian princess who
brought him up close to the top of
Egyptian society I mean mothers would
have known Pharaoh and had an Egyptian
education but fundamentally he was a
Hebrew and became the leader of the then
enslaved people and led them out of
Egypt across the Sinai desert and to
what we now call roughly Israel called
Canaan in those days when did he live
1250 BC I said would be a good date say
he lived to be 120 years old those are
symbolic figures they just mean very old
the Egyptian said 110 and we were
talking earlier about Dostoevsky dusty
have ski and crime and punishment I
wrote down about rust kalmakov he
anticipates the cataclysmic themes of
the 20th century nihilism mass murder
savagery ideology ideology and
totalitarianism mm-hmm explain all that
and did you by the way you read crime
and punishment when you're in Columbia
yes I told up there yeah you taught
crime in pants and what is it about
Raskolnikov few
is important well he commits a brutal
murder with the idea that he is a
superior man and he's beyond good and
evil how old is he when he does this
he's a law student or fails law student
who thinks he's Napoleon and one of his
theories is that a great man is beyond
good and evil and can do these things
that's what great men do and when his
dust I ASCII writing this about the end
of the 19th century it turns out that
Raskolnikov's conscience won't let him
get away with it and somebody said I
forgot what what scholar that dusty esky
thought that the unconscious mind was
moral and agreed with Shakespeare on
that point so Raskolnikov's conscience
forces him to admit his guilt to a
detective with a psychological master
yeah I think this is true that you feel
this in Shakespeare to that the
unconscious minds of his characters are
often there there judge and sentencer I
mean Claudius and Hamlet it's in
mentioning Hamlet breasts Colin hot
Raskolnikov has a friend named resume in
which means reason in russia russian and
Hamlet's best friend is Horatio which
also concludes the word Russia you know
the reason to so we have these I think
dusty s who is competing with Hamlet and
writing crime and punishment the crime
in the background the agonizing the
guild the whole thing and I'm sure that
does guess you want to beat Shakespeare
the Western mind is permanently
intention it is dialectical as the
Austrian many others have said you start
off by talking about Western culture in
the Western mind is there anything
special about the Western mind well look
at it what's those powerful part of the
globe what
the science is unbeatable there's no
comparable special Chinese science or
African science and if your Western
where do you live in the civilized world
knows that term civilized world has been
revived since this tower bombing the
civilized world is supposed to be coming
together to defeat terrorism which it
certainly will but yes the the West is
where things are no one willingly goes
to Persia or the Congo is human nature
essentially good capable of being good
but it's not essentially good because
the options are open and you write about
the Vietnam War you say it as a matter
of consensus in the United States at
least this academic mutation and
mutilation had its roots in the era of
the Vietnam War what are you talking
about oh the 60s the spelling of America
with a k instead of a see the whole
ideology of multiculturalism which
really means that we're supposed to
admire all the other cultures accept
western culture the Western culture
doesn't come in into the multi I think
we have just seen the collapse of the
60s project with the outpouring of
patriotism after the bombing all of a
sudden people woke up and said look we
have something very very important here
call the United States or of Western
civilization and the 60s of at last are
over I think you actually said in your
book a little bit add a little bit more
tell you say none of the cultures we are
supposed to be multi about is that all
itself multicultural that's right so
where do we get the idea here that we
should be a multicultural society well
we are a nation of immigrants and the
hope is that they assimilate to the
existing society there's been a surge of
identity politics which value
the difference rather than the
similarities of the different
constituent groups of Americans I think
this is a bad thing and that we should
all be getting together an agreed-upon
norms and i hope i hope that i hope it
works out that way I don't think America
really is a society with a multicultural
future but a society with an American
future we start out by talking about
dinesh d'souza and your teaching any
other folks over the years at Dartmouth
that you taught that went on to having a
public life well former student of mine
and Paul Gigot just became editor of The
Wall Street Journal and a former editor
of the Dartmouth review named Hugo rest
all more recent graduate DePaul as
editor of the Asian Wall Street Journal
and those are two of the most potent
editorial posts in journalism so I'm
very happy about that and I could name a
lot of other students who are doing
excellent things but these are very
visible and certainly dinesh d'souza has
written some his illiberal education and
his book the end of racism are both
terrific works I think and from your
experience as being a life on teacher
what makes a good teacher when do you
know you're doing a good job I think my
experience I've always insisted on
reading all the essays my students turn
in some professors have people read them
but even though I last class had
something like 400 students and it I
read H wrote three essays and I've heard
1200 s size because i want to get
feedback you know i just want to throw
something out there wonder if it's being
absorbed so i get that kind of thing
from reading their papers our guest has
been professor emeritus at Dartmouth
Jeffrey heart and here is his latest
book is eighth book smiling through the
cultural catastrophe thank you very much
sir